autre première mariée c'est un
spécialiste du mariage puisqu'il s'est
marié tellement de fois que son salaire
se transforme automatiquement en pension
alimentaire
benjamin castaldi alors tu vas devoir
dire manif hype ou d'egalite' d'accord
manif avec ou d'egalite' benjamin
castaldi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
attention attention
la joue clubic your way
trop je l'aimais trop alors s'il avait
réclamé les tensions de la scène des
lois du tamani alors magnifique idée du
live des zones et chérif et c'est
dégueulasse
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que tu as un petit mot est-ce que
tu as un petit mot on va pas faire
toutes les femmes parce que c'est trop
long elle tente un petit mot pour aurore
ouais j'avais fait un petit poème vas-y
avignon ses yeux sont plus brillants que
les étoiles les tellement belle que je
lui dis tous les jours et quand je lui
fais des compliments
elle ne croit jamais au niveau 5 fois
jacques goldman
il n'y a pas de rim sont fous des rimes
mais à chaque fois qu'elle me demande
est-ce que tu m'aimes
ma réponse est toujours la même plus que
tout mon coeur tu es monte au mont
soleil et toute ma vie
[Applaudissements]
beauchamp pour toi ah bon
allez on va accueillir notre 2e marié
vous nous dites à vous mettez note 2 à
10 7 1 sur http https pmp mariage la
prochaine marié est une bombe
elle répondait au nom de balsa aller là
qui dit b 9 et 10
[Applaudissements]
l'économie belge
autant de mots
[Applaudissements]
la ville ou le bisou le bisou bisou
demain matin
[Musique]
après mon petit bisou ouais
[Applaudissements]
banquiers et les missions de glam mari
au premier regard direct merci à kelly a
été libre mais reste à paula way
attendait ballon manif haïku d'egalite'
magnifique
[Applaudissements]
alors dites-nous j'aurais pas juste 1000
collant couleur chair ah oui le reste
vous tuer c'est très sexy machine est
recevable mais retombe à retomber
elle va faire sur marie tombé à la
ramasse voilà ce qu'elle va faire avec
son mari son mari tu vas voir ce qui va
arriver dans un instant et elle fricote
avec un garçon de l'équipe ah bon il
fallait la halle tricote pour elle
tricote puisque c'est normal tu vas le
voir
tu vois des bonbons suis également lui
plaît merci a dit merci qui
j'aime la france est marié vous kiffez
les mariés chez booba c'est comme un
repas chaud verse à 8h avoir les mains
sous marine pour la 3e marié
on n'est pas dans le même temps on
change d'univers avec une mariée avec un
physique plutôt différent mais qu'à son
petit charme et l magnifique et elle
dégueulasse
hahaha gilles verdez
[Applaudissements]
mais oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on en reste là alors crise lasky les
manifs à l'écouté glace
il est méga dégueulasse il est comme moi
je peux dire que l'extravagance dire que
tout dans un sens ça pouvait être
magnifique
serait-ce que non mais parce qu'il ya un
côté strabag oran gars qui partent
parfois ça peut être sympa tout
fonctionne pas on va bosser
moi je trouve qu'il ya quelque chose
d'indécent évolue le nez les laisserai
allait l'appliquent sol et sur la
silhouette est belle silhouette et 28e
gilles un brillant la salle à paupières
qui tombe tellement dégueulasse qu'on
doit de teint devient pâle et fine
merci merci
attention notre quatrième marié tu ne
c'est une personne qu'on aime beaucoup
elle est très belle dans sa robe
ça va lui rappeler son mariage célébré
par rené coty en personne je vous
demande d'applaudir isabelle morini bosc
le bas
[Applaudissements]
qu'elle est belle
c'est banal et c'est bon je t'ai la
haine wang
[Musique]
genève accueille merci ça va mal à
réaliser
alors voilà on va dire c'était
magnifique où c'était dégueulasse
est-ce que tu aurais enlevé quelque
chose déjà le cogner façon technique la
mafa ça fait huit ans ça fait huit ans
que je fais de la télé comme ça la
caméra et la vallée comme ça en tout cas
ça je me suis débarrassé de ma robe de
mariée je pensais pas que je remettrai
une autre jeu il se trouve que la robe
elle est très très très joli ouais mais
ce qui va pas c'est les bijoux qui
sépare le même style
les bijoux là on dirait que tu les as la
robe on dirait qu'elle a acheté c'est
dingue au couturier et la tue les
acheter sur la plage avec des shootings
sam et rigole pas on dirait que tu as
pris sans rien et on dirait que le mec
tu as dit mais moi de beignets aimez-moi
trois colliers aussi pour le kiff
mais mais mais vous n auriez vous auriez
enlever les colliers cité un sans faute
pour moi mais oui et les chaussures
aussi des chaussures mais bon c'est le
mariage quand même il ya des bruits à la
pole temps d'enlever les se battent moi
je dirais je dirais que c'est un
magnifique c'est pas dégueulasse la
nefac mais parce que tu es belle vas tu
es belle déjà d'origine
bah oui on va enchaîner avec la mariée
qui je pense va être la plus triste du
monde
j'ai très peur de voir le résultat non
on va pas le mettre tout de suite ayant
pas mettre tout de suite si les sept
c'est très dur c'est le plus haut on va
accueillir le marié mais c'est vrai ou
est plaisant c'est même travail que le
blanc est signe de virginité ça tombe
bien ce qu'il s'agit là de maxime
daigneault
[Applaudissements]
moi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous
[Musique]
là les hawks avizou la ville
comment il se la pète lui sert pas du
rein gauche au sénat devrait fléchir et
de la magnifique
ah oui elle est magnifique elle a
d'ailleurs n'est pas tu n'es pas mais
toi tu n'es pas bon tu n'es pas donc je
suis super fier comme ça ça j'en dirais
que tu vas chez paou l église je sais
rien moi sans fin tu vas pas l'église
pour te marier donc c'est vrai monsieur
au service du pense de lui il a un
potentiel lui normalement il est mignon
comme tout les bonnes et les mauvaises
personnes qu'elle a choisi la mauvaise
tenue ça va pas la sophrologie
mais la gâteau chapeau sera belle c'est
le chapeau qui toi c'est les chapeaux la
robe ça se passe par ici le dégueulasse
merci à l'été nicolas la revue à les
cherry bomb accueillir maintenant celui
qu'on attendait c'est bien sûr notre ami
jean michel maire
j'ai très peur de voir le résultat est
juste pour que vous sachiez il y à
bouder avec nous aujourd'hui dans
l'équipe
donc si vous allez voir là vous allez
voir jean-michel et à mon avis ce sera
encore au dessus jean michel maire c'est
parti
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
allez alors maintenant tout bien sûr
hashtag angoisse un stade angoisses de
lille non sur la tête de ma mère mais
parce que vous en fait le problème c'est
que vous êtes limite un peu trop dans le
rôle second problème c'est à dire là
normalement c'est ça cette séquence là
est directement le commissariat c'est
directement ya pas de voile assez
directement la case voilà non mais mais
jean michel vous jouez le rôle vous
jouez toujours les choses à four comment
vous le trouver ah mais moi je trouve
qu'il a joué le rôle à fond et bien aimé
les personnages il marche très bien
talent j'adorais cher et à une entrée
triomphale et pour cela je donne ma
nissan
waly faye oui
bisous
toi
la logique aurait fait du bien de
retrouver son cousin c'est moi qui tiens
kebaba soir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la sai baba partait tous les deux assez
fait attention aux traces sur le temps
voilà là on va cueillir une vraie marier
très variés sachez qu'elle a été élu par
l'ensemble de mes potes la meuf la plus
fraîche du paf
mais mes potes veulent tous la pécho ah
bon car ils sont tous comme des oufs sur
l avoue alors avoir été bien que c'est
pas bouder même si on aime beaucoup
agathe au pont
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sur des sommes deux étages tous et merci
merci car c'est le riz qui s'est collé
vous aimez mais moi je te trouve manif à
la chérie de simple superposition des
cruches ta mère elle va s'élever à
checker et oussama des folles salah
alors tu restes là tu t'entends ce
qu'elle dit christina et c'est oui qui
la transparence avec le soutien gorge
mais même temps tu as même col roulé sa
défaire un peu sage dans les transports
est pile le voile comme saku je trouve
ça sublissime machine
[Applaudissements]
mettez vous plaisir et vous lancer oula
ça
[Musique]
saga
[Applaudissements]
alors avant que tu nous donnes tu va
nous donner dans un instant tu as marié
que tu as trouvé la plus belle et vous
aussi on va voir le résultat des
téléspectateurs juste avant il en reste
une
d'accord c'est la dernière tamera diffic
je vous demande d'applaudir bouder
[Applaudissements]
m
à chaque fois qu'une émission je suis
déguisé en main mais retirer le fils de
la houle se calme a tenu à ce que de
gaulle ait bientôt s'étonner de sang
alors alors est-ce qu'ils aient des
gaules halsou manif à la cuve du mr
chibani goût des saveurs
ça va pas le faire toi papa la balle
alors à ça tu vas pas te sépares
morphologie oui ça face tu fais parfois
un bobard faut loger aérien qui m'a
alors alors on me dit qu'un dernier
couple qui s'est formé
car il ya un mariage qui est en train de
se créer qui s'est créé dans les loges
mouvement d'hier de demandes et
d'applaudir et d'accueillir les mariés
surprise ils sont avec nous poussez vous
s'il vous plaît ils sont là
applaudissements pour eux
[Musique]
voilà
on a six
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le salon est un peu chère à ce niveau là
ça fait mouler êtes un peu mou les
jeunes élevés seraient que dans le
milieu du salon on appelle un coup là
non mais c'est sa à lausanne en tout cas
vous êtes magnifique vraiment et un seul
s'ils n'avaient pas le temps de vous
seriez vous avez fait l'émission d'avant
voilà mais si vous avez confié à votre
mariage mais un carton non mes marques
je suis bon pour le lancer ce qu'ils
attrapent sera mariée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
là bas alors que cela mais tu voles une
soupe et quel est pour toi la mariée la
plus manning est la plus dégueulasse et
la la alors j'ai commencé par la bdl ait
la bonne nouvelle après alors non
comment ils commencent par la plus
dégueulasse à la joie du public d'abord
oui oui oui on va regarder le bot de
public les chéris ah bah voilà c'est
kelly apparemment non quelle est la plus
belle des débats riez et gilles verdez
qui est le plus dégueulasse là pourquoi
c'est qu'ils soient c'est qui moi
j'aurais pas fait nous y perdre s reçoit
je suis au crédit il est je trouve qu'il
est tellement rhin qui devient attendant
c'est quoi cet indice le plus
dégueulasse et castaldi est là et qui
revient dès la prime à l'échec
majed trouvera la superposition lapin
gaffe à la plus bas niveau et le choix